an actor that could return to Stargate
that completely surprised me and may
have already been approached about a
role
what his return means though is massive
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so yes I've still got a call so yes I'm
still a bit bunged up and I don't want
to leave your suspense for too long but
I just have to explain that
um people I speak to at Amazon have told
me that there's been a lot of research
and a lot of preparation work being done
for this new Stargate series one of the
things they did as a marketing and
strategy plan was to look at the actors
that appeared in Stargate before and
consider which ones would have the most
impact if they were to return in some
sort of Cameo now I did tell you in the
previous video Richard Dean Amerson
topped that list he would have the most
impacting would be most popular with
gators if he was to return in at least
in some sort of cameo role and I also
told you second on that list was
somebody that really surprised me it was
Robert Carlisle so everything happens
for a reason
yeah well if you just said that to me a
couple of years ago and it dismissed his
superstition
now Robert Carlyle is an actor I
absolutely adore I imagine he is I've
managed to get on this list not mainly
because of the
um impact and the the Gators love him
with which we do but I think it's
probably more to do that he is still a
very
um involved actor he's still a very high
profile working actor and the way they
put this list together was not just to
look at
um sort of like his popularity with
gators but how many clicks he gets on
different websites how many times his
name's brought up in different things so
I imagine that's how he's got on this
list
but the important thing is that Amazon
now consider him to be a really
important actor to potentially return to
Stargate and a new Stargate franchise
I can also tell you through other
sources that I speak to that this rumor
isn't just a rumor and they might
actually be taking this very seriously
but I will tell you about that in a
second because obviously the really
exciting thing to talk about is that if
Robert Carlisle does return to a
Stargate franchise
what does that mean for a conclusion to
Stargate Universe now Stargate Universe
is a little bit of a Marmite sort of
situation with gators
um if you're British you'll understand
that reference if you're American not so
much but it basically means that we
either love or hate Stargate Universe I
personally found Stargate Universe a
little boring
um but I could see that it was getting
better
um I'll tell you that like I was a
Trekkie when I was younger Star Trek the
Next Generation was my favorite TV show
on the planet the first series of that
was kind of boring so the fact that I
found SGU boring does not mean that I
think this series should have been
canceled it shouldn't have been it was
getting better and it was getting more
interesting
there are a lot of people out there
though that consider starting a universe
to be the best iteration of Stargate and
are still incredibly angry we never got
a conclusion
if they are going to bring back rubber
Carlisle into a new Stargate franchise
obviously that means they have to get
him off the destiny they have to bring
him home now how do you do that I have
no clue
I only know that Destiny has come
this far and if we abandon Allah
there'll be no coming back
don't forget to like subscribe and hit
the Bell notification so you don't miss
any of our new videos and also if you
want to become a fully fledged side
tracker and you want to really support
the channel consider hitting the join
button and on this channel we've talked
a lot about getting out there and saving
Eli Eli was the one actor that we were
pretty sure that could return to
Stargate he is still a working actor but
not particularly successful and if he
was offered the role he would snap it up
I'm absolutely certain also though from
a storyline point of view I argued that
Eli was the one that was still awake
obviously and that if you were going to
bring back actors from the destiny you
can't bring back all of them because
that's just not practical I mean we we
want all the actors we want all the
characters to be saved and to come home
but for me production point of view it
would be very very difficult
so bringing back one or two and then
writing into the story that the stasis
pods were lost or something else sort of
made sense to me so we would get to see
some sort of conclusion to Stargate
Universe if Robert Carlisle comes back
but also we would get the Rush character
back now Rush was a character that
people love to hate
my friends
oh yes perhaps that's a
an overstatement at very least at first
we grew to love him more but the main
reason why I was always such a big fan
of Rush not just because of the
confrontations he caused not because of
he was quite a slimy character but just
because Robert Carlisle is a brilliant
actor he's been brilliant in pretty much
everything he's ever done he's just a
likable proper actor and if they were to
get him to return to the Stargate
franchise he would be a properly big
name to get to that franchise
that is the main reason why you got the
job in SGU in the first place and he was
the main known star in that Series so
you would get somebody with properly
good acting skills you would get
somebody that is a well-known name that
people would recognize on the poster you
would get a character in Rush that is
well liked and sometimes hated but at
least you're interested by him and you
would get a conclusion to Stargate
Universe
now is this just a room or is this just
fantasy well no because one of the
people I speak to that um used to work
at MGM actually but now works for a
different agency within Hollywood has
told me that he is aware that Robert
Carlisle has been approached now
that doesn't necessarily mean that he
would ever appear in Stargate but it
does mean that his agent has been
approached it doesn't mean that he was
sounded out about if Stargate returns
would he be interested and apparently
there was a positive response through
the agent back to MGM so that means
Robert Carlisle was asked do you fancy
it and Robert Carlisle went yeah okay
I'd very least like to see the script
which is a positive start now we're not
going to get any further than that at
the moment because we don't have any
official announcement on
um a showrunner we don't have any
official announcements on Stargate at
all through this channel I've been able
to tell you that penguin and Parker and
Mark fergus's and Hawk host Beast
company is currently negotiating
something to do with Stargate we believe
it is to show run but it might only be
to develop a new series we just don't
know yet and we know recently with
things like the God of War TV series
that Hawk Osby and Mark Fergus are also
going to be involved in again I hear
that Mark Fergus is really going to be
concentrating on Stargate if they get
this project and Hawk ospi is actually
the one that is most interested in God
of War project so even though they will
both be executive producers and working
on both projects together they will be
splitting the focus so until we get sort
of that development until we actually
until I'm Amazon actually decide the
direction they want to take Stargate
because Mark Fergus needs to decide on a
direction we can't confirm that Robert
Carlisle would return because they might
not want him to but at the moment we can
say he is at least interested and more
importantly Amazon are interested
because they know his return would have
a big impact and they know his return
could lead to storylines that the Agata
fans would go absolutely crazy for
so again if this rumor is true it really
could answer some of the big questions
left over from the Stargate franchise
when it got canceled we could actually
get to find out what the Destiny's
Mission really was and more importantly
where the destiny is now if you are new
to the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification so you don't miss
any of our new videos and if you really
want to support the channel consider
hitting the join Button as always guys
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]